Speaker 1: Let's see if we can
squeeze somebody else in here.
What about? You're going to have to be sort
of quick, But how about Vance from the Atlanta
suburbs? Vance. Welcome. What's on your mind?
Speaker 4: Hi, David. Can you hear me okay?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 3: Okay. So my question is,
how would the 2016 election season have
gone if, like, Hillary Clinton was a man,
like everything else about her was the same, But
she wasn't a woman. She was just a man. But, you.
Speaker 1: Know, it was serious. It was it was
so close. It was so close. That if being a woman
cost Hillary just a few votes in some critical
states, you could argue that would have been a
difference maker. But here's the thing. I also
want to add to that, Vince. There are so many
single things that could have been difference
makers if James Comey didn't do the second press
conference about Hillary Clinton, if you know,
So you can play this game all day long. There are
a million different factors. What was the weather
on Election Day or all these different things?
I think that it's an interesting question
to ask. The answer is I'm sure the outcome,
the vote totals would have differed somewhat
from what they were if Hillary Clinton were a
man. But I don't know how useful as a general
way to analyze elections, how useful it is.
Speaker 3: Of. Okay. Well, thanks for.
Thanks for having me. That's all I have.
Speaker 1: All right. Vance from the Atlanta
suburbs. And on that note, we will call it a
day for live calls. We will take calls again.
And when we do, I'm telling you right now,
I hope to hear from you. We'll take a quick
break and be right back with much more.